hi good evening all
a quick audio trip i hope you're able to
hear me
good evening and a very warm welcome to
each one of you
uh it's a great evening that we're here
to celebrate your success
uh thank you for everyone who's
confirming um this is our first
online convocation program the year 2021
purdue and simply learn so we're really
excited to have you here to celebrate
your journey of success right this
entire program uh
this is not something which is very easy
to achieve
and hence it at this moment deserves a
lot of celebration
and i'm subhashini chandran i work as a
senior program manager
at simply learn with the data and ait
it's a
it's a very proud moment and an honor to
be part of the celebration and
and share the journey with you
here's a quick snapshot of how your
entire journey has been
when i said this is not an easy thing to
achieve this is what i meant
six to ten months a week in classes
hundreds of hours of learning
so many assessments and projects and
intense capstone projects
and eventually you you reach the point
of you know graduation and receiving the
certificate
and uh very well done kudos to you uh
each one of you have
gone the extra mile to make this happen
and i think this is
a very well deserved moment to celebrate
each one of you
thank you so much and congratulations
before we start the program i would like
to introduce
our sponsor anna narayan
narayanan chief product officer at
simplylearn
so our leader our product leader he
believes in a rapid iterative
lean approach to delivering products and
constant and continuous
customer and sales feedback but that
what i really want to
convey is that anand is somebody who
who literally watches every step of what
we take
to kind of deliver the kind of service
that we offer to you and what we
we say we will deliver and it's really a
pleasure to have ananth here today
with us a little introduction about ana
a little more details
so he's completed his computer science
in the national institute of
institute of technology karnataka his
master's program from texas at am
university
mba in general management from the
university of texas at austin
uh at simply learn he has peer-headed
multiple initiatives
and here mentioned are just a couple you
know what he's done and
he's built out products that simply
learned that have won innovation awards
and are used by fortune companies and
you know with a greater than 70
nps and i'm sure you'd agree that's not
an easy thing to do
um he's the winner of multiple awards
just a few that are
mentioned out there uh ana it's a
pleasure to have you here
and i request you to share a few words
with our learners today
so thank you for embarrassing me here in
a pretty large forum
but you know honestly this is not about
me today i think let's forget about
why i'm here and you know what's
happening i think the most important
thing is to partially called it out
right
i will tell you something i'll tell you
a secret what you all have achieved and
there are 93 94 folks who are actually
here that have graduated
i will tell you a secret that i could
not achieve what you would achieve
and what you have achieved quite
transparently right and the reason i say
that is
i looked at the learners who are in this
group and you see the kind of people who
are showing up here today
highly accomplished very very capable
people who have a day job
and potentially a night job and then you
do this program and you graduate through
a pretty grueling program
which takes you through a journey of
multiple skills and multiple courses and
here you are and
you're done and i can tell you how many
times i have taken an online course and
failed
and those are just video courses right
so first of all i want to just
take you know all of you guys to take a
step back pat yourself on the back
massive achievement amazing i'm so proud
of all of you to have taken this program
and gotten this far
and you know i will talk about a little
bit about the cohort and how you've come
this far as well
so just to give you a little bit of
background you know you probably are
here you take the classes you see the
folks around you
and you see what's going on i want to
call out something which first of all
will boggle your mind
you'll find that almost 51 of the folks
who are here have at least eight years
of experience
and you'll find that if you start taking
five plus years again experience levels
of the
cohorts that you're part of it's pretty
pretty high experienced
group and so what does that mean the
kind of people that you're actually here
with that you're graduating with today
and the folks that you've been learning
with these are people who are going
places they're going to achieve great
things and so are you
and so keep in touch with each other
right you have each other's community
forums the forums are still there
make sure you stay in touch with the
folks that are here and who are
graduating today because guess what
these are achievers i'll just call it a
few other things you'll notice that
uh you know 48 of the folks here have a
at least a bachelor's degree
you'll see that there are mbas masters
degrees engineering degrees and even
phds here in this group right so
um frankly i feel very small when i sit
here and look at the kind of people who
are actually here in this cohort who are
actually graduating
pretty amazing right and you'll find
that the the the
spread of the kind of background that
you've brought to the table
it's also pretty wide you'll find that
from engineering to information
technology to consulting or even finance
there's a wide spread of people who are
actually showing up here
and the other thing i want to share is
this is a truly global audience
roughly about 15 to 20 of the people are
actually us or
europe or australia or you know middle
east based and about
75 to 80 of them are india based right
so it's a pretty global group that is
here
and of course you have a good gender mix
as well here considering this is a very
technical product that
you all have gone through so first of
all i just want to summarize this slide
a little bit
the cohort that you're in the folks that
are here today highly accomplished
pretty amazing set of folks who have
made it this far don't lose touch with
each other this is your journey post
simply learn
keep in touch with each other you're not
purdue alumni uh you're all you know
purdue folks and keeping in touch with
each other and making sure this journey
doesn't end here is very important
so great great uh looking at the cohort
mix that we have here
let's go to the next slide
again we can move on to the next slide
thank you anand thank you for
sharing your thoughts here that was
really kind advice of you
next up i would like to introduce our
guest of honor this evening uh dr
patrick wolf
before we even get into the details of
his achievements just want to call out
that
patrick is kind of known as a very
humble person that we could work with
and we've had a great experience working
with dr patrick
so here are some of his achievements so
he's received the presidential early
career award for scientists and
engineers from the white house in 2008
named the distinguished lecturer in data
science by the ieee in 2018
he served as a royal society research
fellow and as the founding executive
director
of ucl's big data institute worked as a
faculty member at cambridge
harvard and university college london
he's received his phd from the
university of cambridge
in 2003. we're really happy to have you
here patrick
if arjun if you could just check
i think you'll have to unmute dr patrick
because he was not able to join the
panelists queue directly could you
please check that for me
and maybe just to help sebastiani i
think uh patrick might be having
technical difficulties in joining i know
he joined us and we weren't able to get
him
uh on the panel so my suggestion is
let's continue and let's celebrate the
learners and patrick whenever he's
you know connected and ready to go we'll
bring him back on stage
thank you anand thank you arjun can we
move on to the next slide
right so like adam did mention the
entire day today is all about
you so we are here just to celebrate
your success really
uh so something that we wanted to check
with you is how was your journey really
so today
of course we're all celebrating success
but this might not have been easy for
you
it must have been difficult for some
maybe an easy journey for
for many maybe you did not even realize
that you did this but you achieved it
eventually
so we just wanted to do a sense check
with you so uh we would we would quickly
run a poll with you
if you could share your feedback with us
that would be very helpful
so let's do it if you could help me with
the poll please hello patrick
i see you were able to join yeah
wonderful after the poll we'll hand it
over to patrick so patrick give us
a couple minutes to go to the polls and
hand it over to you
to let us know when it's the poll starts
i'm sorry i'm just checking has the pole
started
arjun can you confirm please
i i think there's there's a bit of a
delay um i think we will move on to
patrick yeah
yeah let's just jump in right so let's
make it interactive and let's do it the
way it happens in class right so i think
you're all used to using the chat
modules
um on a scale there you go all right
wonderful actually the poll came up
finally
so i think the question here really is
and please be honest right some of you
might have struggled some of you might
have found it really easy
how difficult was the journey to reach
this very point uh
love to hear how that spread looks like
i think we've got another 20 seconds or
so left so please choose your uh
twice
let's give another 10 seconds
all right thank you that is a really
nice comment to read
i'm glad very impressive especially
since you were non-technical and you
were able to complete the program all
right let's look at how the response is
for the larger group
all right very interesting subashri and
patrick if you notice
a majority says it's fairly difficult
right
and some of them are like yeah it's kind
of in the middle which is quite
impressive if you're one of those folks
i'm actually impressed because i don't
think i can complete this program
and then there are just these few people
who said look this is super easy
uh well maybe it's time for you to take
the next level here
but wonderful back to you sebastian i
think over to patrick once uh you know
after this poll
thank you thank you anand for stepping
in so over to you patrick
uh sorry there was some technical issues
i believe but i'm glad you're here
so uh it would be great to hear from you
uh patrick
learners would be happy to hear from you
over to you
and thank you everybody and yes i was uh
following along but i was in the
graduation participants list rather than
the panelists list so i'm very sorry
about that
but uh i would i would happily take my
degree but i don't think i've done all
the course work just yet
i want to kind of give everyone my you
know sort of very hearty
and warmest well-deserved
congratulations
um i think uh as as others have said
it's uh it's no small feat to accomplish
this
and um i'll keep my remarks pretty brief
but
i just wanted to um to kind of remind
you a little bit about
uh how important this journey is and uh
and the sort of vistas that
that await you now now i've had a chance
to
interact with many of you through the
master classes that we've held
did we lose patrick can't hear
patrick i think we lost your audio
regular interval
there we go is that any better i came on
again
can hear you now all right excellent
sorry about that
i guess this it's gone again patrick
sorry can't hear you
i think we lost patrick and we'll hope
he comes back in a few seconds
all right patrick we'll come back to you
we'll continue with the rest of the
agenda uh
yeah let's continue
arjun right
same experience
patrick i think there is a bit of a gap
in the audio
we can't hear you patrick
for now let's move on to the next slide
right so we clearly are stepping into
the most exciting part of this evening
like like we keep mentioning that this
is about you and
definitely we want to focus a lot more
on how your experience
experience has been and kind of hear
from you because a lot of times we don't
really get to hear from you directly of
course we get your feedback we always
get your feedback but this i think is a
great opportunity
and some of your peers have volunteered
to share their experience with us today
and we would we would like to invite
them
to share their experience right now so i
request
stewart to allow a learners to switch on
the video and the audio as i call out
the name
the first up would be shibodi batacharya
i hope i got your name right so let's do
it audrey if you can help me with that
please
can you help shaboody switch on the
video and audio
so he could share his experience with us
arjun please to confirm if you're able
to do that
i can't hear you shibuti i'm not sure if
they've unmuted you yet can't hear you
i did see your video come on for a
second
are you able to hear me i am not able to
hear you yet
and are you able to hear deep just to
continue yeah i think
got some audio issues right right
so should we start with the second
person and then we will come back to you
if that's okay
uh next up would be rajesh nagarjunan so
if we have rajesh ready
rajesh can you go first and then we will
have shabadeep speak
i see you're in the panelist group now
so you should be able to switch on your
video and audio
please do try
all right i can hear you and you can see
me as well i take it
i am awesome
oh thanks very much for this opportunity
so
uh a little bit about myself as i start
um
you know i have a bachelor's in
engineering specializing in electronics
and communications
went down to do my masters in business
and have about 25 years of experience
right in various sectors including
um i've been in startups in the bay area
moved on to investment banks in
singapore hong kong sweden and settled
in the uk
over the last um about 15 years
and um currently work in energy sector
consulting on large transformations to
support a delaware net zero
commitment um for the uk um so that's
the transformation i'm on
and um and really my motivation to do
this program was
um was all about continued learning
right so
i think the future of the world is very
much
um robotics machine learning artificial
intelligence
and um and it's just a fantastic space
um
the only uh sad part is after 25 years
of experience
just getting the drive and the
motivation to sit and
uh you know get back into basics was
proving to be such a huge challenge
right so um
well i did try various things like i
bought books started reading i
um you know while i travel to london in
the train and back
and always find time to squeeze things
there but no it was it wasn't enough
right so i needed something more
structured i needed something more
you know um something where i could get
a bit of guidance
help and where something a bit more
comprehensive so i know that
when i get to the end of it i know okay
i've done something it means i have some
level of knowledge
and i can go on to face the real one
right so i think
that was the thought that was running
but i think it was daunting like really
you know at about 45 46 you know i was
starting to write code and python and
you know getting through things was it
wasn't easy by any means
and the big bigger motivation in drive
was i had a few friends who
also had the same thought you know all i
draw about my age you know one from
singapore and the other from india
um and we all grouped together and said
yeah why don't we take this challenge
why don't we just get on this
you know course um kill ourselves every
weekend with families young
old and then go through this um
grilling to get this course done right
so
we launched on it with my one of my best
friends okay
from singapore and my other really best
friend and also my sister sangeeta
uh you know and we said okay let's get
on this but
you know what we thoroughly enjoyed it
he was uh
he was it was pain right many times it
was just pain
we we're all in big um you know uh
responsible roles
in various places where my sister's a
director and a bank and
you know ours is uh um you know running
large teams in singapore and stuff
and we're busy all the time but we
somehow managed to find that overlap
where we could work together
and challenge ourselves and get through
the course right so
in terms of the course itself i would
say you know
a we were supporting each other during
this entire period motivating ourselves
keeping in place working on assignments
and you know assignments weren't easy
every week there was one two maybe even
three right
to get along with and through the week
and weekdays we were challenging each
other
and but it was it was enjoyable part of
my
life i would say it was one of the most
enjoyable learning
um you know periods um and we also made
some
great friends in the group right like i
mean amber apita many others
whom i think we'll stay in touch for a
much longer period in time
and finally our teachers i mean simply a
lot i think you guys have done a great
job right so
you know in all families it's not easy
to find
you know teachers who invest time and
energy and come and teach with some
level of
experience on weekends and doing all
this online
is not by any means easy right um
and with people sitting different parts
of the globe and some really tired and
sleepy and all that
but i think they were up for the
challenge you know some were good some
were extremely good you know and
some just made sure that you know we
even got through some of the most
complex topics
and they never uh you know let us go
without it i mean for me personally it
was nlp right
um natural language processing which i
kind of struggled a little bit until i
really got a hang of things right so you
know at the end of it what has it done
to me right
you know i feel super confident i should
say that right
there's no hiding you know on machine
learning and artificial intelligence
and data science in general and in fact
i'm currently exploring
computer vision and ai generative art
right for
nfts and other stuff it seems like a
really cool thing i'm getting my hands
down
and dirty and i'm confident i can do it
right i can get a library
of the web i can use killers i can use
other sorts of libraries and go cracking
with it right so
that's something that i came i also went
on to do blockchain and
cryptos at the back of it i would never
have had the courage to
open something up like that and start
working on it but i've done it and
which is just a testimony to the
grilling i've been put through right
over the last year and more importantly
you know i would say simply learn you
know the service was great
um it was scary at times very suspicious
how is all this going to work you know
is it going to be straightforward easy
but i should say i mean there are
glitches right like any other place
there are going to be glitches but you
know the service was great
it was very responsible um you know
people who are very responsible
very responsive and always very helpful
too
right so thank you um you know simply
learning
and all of you and uh for giving us
a lovely platform an opportunity
and equally simply learn and purdue um
you know for the opportunity great
opportunity i should say
and i just feel thrilled and very
grateful so thank you
rajish i'm truly inspired that was
amazing
thank you thank you rajesh so we could
definitely sense the passion and
the excitement that the journey has you
know given you so thank you so much for
sharing your experience
thank you rajesh have a good one good
luck everybody thank you
so super deep if you're ready we'll go
next with you
hey all can you hear me yes brilliant
okay finally okay
all right so um
well i mean hi to everyone and good
morning and good evening
wherever you are and um hopefully
all of you and your family is staying
safe
and staying healthy in these difficult
times
um a little bit about myself and my
journey uh
i have a bachelor of engineering um
in from india and then i have also
completed
my mba from the us and
overall i have about 13 plus years of
work experience
and the majority of my work experience
has been
in the line of data and analytics
however the focus of my work has
primarily been
in diagnostic and descriptive analytics
the the traditional uh data warehousing
and bi concepts uh if some of you may
know that right
um and so um back in about 2019
2018 2019 uh the whole
you know world of ml ai the chatter
around
mlai was starting to become very
significant and um it it meant
it it gave me a cue that it is you know
perhaps time that
i needed to upskill myself uh given that
i am from a technology background and in
the technology background
it's very important to always stay
abreast
with the latest technology developments
uh
the the concepts the patterns right
and uh i needed to move my you know uh
skills as well as
uh move my work uh more from a
diagnostic and a descriptive
data analytic workspace to more towards
a
predictive and a prescriptive kind of a
a workspace
and due to which um it was
quite evident to me that i had to
upskill myself
in in the in the world of data science
ai
ml and
and i'm always you know curious to learn
new things and you know keep myself
updated
and and that's how i kind of enrolled
myself in this program
of course i looked around as anyone
would and
i went through the the program structure
um
the the counselor at the beginning
helped me also understand
about the program the program structure
the pedagogy as
well as then the various uh you can say
courses and the projects that are part
of the program
and then it was quite evident to me that
this program
is going to suit my lifestyle it will
allow me
to uh you know pursue this program
while also having a day job as well as a
young family to
you know manage and look after right so
you know it was not a very difficult
decision for me to kind of pursue this
program
from simply learn along with purdue
which is one of the very reputed
universities in the us
and looking back i would say that
i have thoroughly enjoyed the journey
it's
been a very rewarding journey i
you know when i when i started of course
i was pretty much zero
in the world of ml and ai however when
i've now graduated i feel
very you know comfortable and confident
in the world of ml and ai
and to the extent that even i've
continued my journey
have cleared some of the you can say
vendor certifications from microsoft
in the line of ml and ai and
that perhaps would not have been
possible had i not uh
really had the base set up right through
the program that i have pursued with
simply learn
so the journey has been very fruitful of
course the peer group that i had
was very motivated and we kind of relied
on each other
for you know support whenever there was
any you know support needed
as well as uh you know educational
information
um and additional resources being shared
by the peer groups
and not only the peer group but the
instructors themselves have been
very they are very knowledgeable they
come from
the industry with a good industry
experience and the industry background
and they have really helped us uh you
know really shared how
world or how the work of mlai really
looks in the real world right
as well as sharing additional resources
with us so
overall it's been a very good learning
for me and
projects wise flexibility wise
instructor-wise everything has lined up
quite well for me
and you know i'm i'm pretty happy that
i have been able to you know
successfully complete the program
as well as you know would like to
congratulate everyone else who has you
know gone through the journey and
completed the program uh from simply
learn and purdue
and um of course i continue to look um
or i continue to educate myself and keep
building my skills and the world of ml
and ai it just feels like
you know this is such a vast area of
study and research it's never ending and
sometimes it's daunting but then
you know it's important that we keep
taking small baby steps to
continue to upscale and you know become
keep becoming relevant in this in this
space
uh so that's it i guess thank you all
thank you to simply learn thank you to
purdue but you for this
uh nice program and um
thank you to everyone who has made this
program success
from uh even the support staff you know
the
the tickets we raise you know mostly
they're being addressed on time
um as well as any other queries that
we've raised have been addressed
uh of course there is room to always
improve but overall i think
uh you know it's been a rewarding
journey
and um i thank simply learn and purdue
for the same
yeah thank you thank you thank you that
was brilliant thank you so much for
sharing your experience and
pointing out everything that's worked
for you um very well done
congratulations to you as well
so we do have a lot of learners who who
have expressed interest to speak but we
will quickly listen to two more
appears and then we will move on so i
request
sahaj hernan if you're ready to share
your experience please
hello hello all uh am i audible
yes you are audible
uh yeah hi uh i'm says
um i'm an m tech from my radisson
car that's my education and i am eight
years of experience in supply chain
management
i'm also an ex-entrepreneur and one year
back
i closed my own company which i had been
running for three years
which was kind of unfortunate uh but
this life experience has taught me that
if you want to live a successful life
and a happy life
then follow your passion
uh may make your passion as your uh
as your profession and uh having worked
with uh maybe like
uh data in excel sheets throughout the
professional career has made me realize
that
this this data excites me a lot i mean
uh
analyzing the data working with the data
uh finding insights from the data
that excites me a lot and that is why i
was motivated to take up this course
uh like uh and and uh honestly
uh unlike many people here i was not
interested in like uh
maybe uh for a better job opportunity
i was not interested in getting a
promotion or a better place
but i was more interested in uh
learning uh learning something which
actually excites me learning something
which interests me
learning something which might help me
get a job in the future uh which is my
own
interest and of course in the future
one day i might become a full-fledged
data scientist
i really pray and therefore i joined
this
program uh before joining this program
i didn't have any experience in the
field of data science
didn't have any experience in the field
of coding i had never coded in
before this but the course was
such easily designed i mean like it was
so simply designed
that i was able to grasp all the
concepts and i was able to do it
very easily uh so i think uh
that was how the course was
really really good uh of course
we need to spare time uh we need to be
dedicated we need to be interested we
need to spare times
for the studies and that of course some
of us have done it and those
of us are here uh to
get the past they get the degree in the
uh i will like there are there were so
many projects
in the course that i'm sure the people
who have
uh completed most of the projects will
definitely have the confidence
to make a career
personally speaking i do want to switch
my job
and become a machine learning engineer
or a data scientist in the future
i'm not sure when i'll be able to get
that
but i'm definitely sure that this course
has
helped me has given me the confidence
that after i switch the job
and become a machine learning engineer
or data scientist uh
i'll be able to apply my knowledge and
the skills
and get the job done uh thanks to all
the teachers
who have helped us to teach patiently
and answered all my questions i had a
lot of questions during the course
everyone knows that
and thank you for patiently answering
all the questions
and thank you simply learn for
connecting
with all the good teachers thank you
thank you thank you sarge
once again thank you so much for sharing
your experience so every word that you
spoke
definitely showed us you know the the
journey what it's given you
um you're up next um obviously the last
one always kind of has to sacrifice on
time
so quickly if you could share your
journey with us it'd be great
yeah hi hi can you guys hear me yes can
hear you
loud and clear okay so do i need to
switch on my camera
it would be great if you could but uh no
pressure
all right okay okay hi
hi so uh uh so
first of all uh thanks a lot for you
know coming up with this
event i mean it's been a long i've uh
you know been it's been a long and
hectic journey
you know so during this pandemic time
it's been
it's been very hectic you know with my
office work etc but let me just uh
walk you through a bit into my journey
so i
am an engineer by trade uh you know i've
got
about 16 years of experience
into the industry i did my bachelor's
and master's from
indian institute of technology delhi uh
you know post that i got into the
product space
you know so uh past 16 years i've
built and scaled almost six products uh
so far
uh you know and being into a product
you know being a product person you know
we've always
loved data and we've always loved
decision making from data
so and and artificial intelligence or
machine learning you know so
the concept i got introduced with this
about almost 11 years back you know 10
2010
you know so i used to work with a large
e-commerce
uh site you know i was heading the
product there
and we were supposed to launch
recommendations on our platform and
that's when
you know we we got introduced with the
concept you know so that's where
so we were working with a spanish
company to to
to to come up with this you know in fact
you know we were the
very first company to launch you know
product recommendations both user-based
recommendations and you know
product-based recommendations so
uh all in all it's been a good
experience and
you know something that motivated me to
you know take up this program is you
know i
always you know as i told you know being
into the product space it becomes very
imperative
for my kind of a guy to uh you know to
love data
and to to be making decisions
based on data and we always have to hear
what our customers say and
what our users are saying etc and
you know uh i've always uh you know
all this while before this program it's
been always off and on
you know i've been learning bits and
pieces from here and there
but yeah you know 2020 was the time when
i finally
you know i thought that i i have some
time now
and let me take this decision to
dedicate some time to
actually work on it uh you know more
seriously because
i was wanting to get into this space
uh you know because you know going
forward i
my my wish is to implement the whole
whole thing in a much larger way uh so
that's why i i got into this
uh something about the program you know
some of the good things i
i like about the program was you know
the whole design of the program uh you
know in the manner
that you know somebody who who comes
across
as a very nervous guy or novice person
you know who doesn't have any idea so
you know so the way it
basically gradually takes you into the
program you know
you know how to deal with the data how
to how to think statistically how to
approach the data statistically and then
you know take a next step into machine
learning then we got into deep learning
and then we got into
a computer vision and then we got into
uh any
natural language processing and so on
and so forth and finally we got into
reinforcement learning and reinforcement
learning if you ask me i mean
the the whole area is still in the state
of of a flux right now you know
things things are really uh really
upcoming you know people are researching
this area et cetera so
it's it it's very interesting to work in
this
wow and and i love to
growth and plan overall globally you
know by
hey tarun i think we are losing you uh
unfortunately live will
thank you thank you thanks a lot guys i
mean i i think i'm
yeah we lost you there and so thank you
so much for
sharing your experience with us but we
did we did get the main part that you
uh that you shared thank you so much and
thanks
yes so fine so so i think uh it's been a
great journey and i
once again uh congratulate uh all my
peers and uh it's been a lovely journey
uh i you know i thank all the simply
learn team and
the purdue university folks uh to design
this program
thanks a lot once again thank you thank
you darren that was really kind of you
so we'll quickly hand it over to patrick
this would be incomplete if we don't
hear from patrick
so uh patrick if if you could share your
words and then we will move on to the
awards section
thank you and uh i'm sorry that we've
all had a little bit of audio trouble
but
uh let me just check hopefully everyone
can hear me now yes we can hear you
patrick
excellent yeah i mean i i actually it's
really nice to have the chance to speak
after hearing
uh from those four uh graduands just
because
i feel like there were some nice common
threads in there
um and i think maybe the thing that
struck me more than anything
was just um kind of everybody noticing
how fresh of an area this is it's the
perfect time to be working in this area
now as graduates you're not just working
in it but you're going
to be also sort of helping to shape it
i think that's really really exciting
that's not the kind of opportunity that
comes along
in anyone's career or certainly in
everyone's career
it requires a little bit of luck and a
little bit of being in the right place
and the right time uh and an awful lot
of perseverance and hard work which is
something that everybody else referenced
so
as i started to say before i just want
to sort of remind everyone that
you're standing on the cusp of an
absolutely amazing experience
this area this whole area of machine
learning analytics data and ai
it's going to continue to grow and to
change
there's lots of cutting-edge research
that's happening
but the best cutting-edge research is
always strongly informed by practice
and practical applications and the
problems that need to be solved
and sort of out there in the real world
so i'll just kind of leave you with the
parting thought
uh to um to be be proud of what you've
accomplished here
uh those of us at purdue we're certainly
proud to have been able to help support
you on this journey
and as you go out and use the skills
that you've learned
you know just remember this is an area
that it needs people like you to help it
stay fresh
don't be shy about taking the learnings
that you see
in any of the jobs and and functions
that you go on to do after this
and you know getting in touch with
colleagues from simply learn or drop me
an email i'm easy i'm my emails patrick
purdue.edu
we're always looking for ways to keep
the research side fresh
and we know you're going to have a
fabulous time
working with this material solving new
problems and uh
and hopefully hopefully you know helping
to drive the future of this area so
i'll sort of stop there and just again
add my hearty and well-deserved
congratulations and it was great to be
able to hear from a few of you
about how meaningful this journey has
been so thank you again and
and warmest congratulations
i'm sorry i was speaking on mute thank
you patrick patrick those were really
nice words that you shared with all of
us with the learners especially
so thank you so much for being there we
will now quickly move on to the the next
section
and and clearly the the most important
section celebrating success so
like like i've mentioned this multiple
times already it's all about you today
so uh the fact that each one of you has
completed the journey that itself is is
a sign of achievement so each one of you
here is an achiever uh so we quickly
want to run through
the the photos that we so we did ask for
photos so that we were able to make a
collage so wherever we managed to get
photos we put it up here
so this the following slides will have
all of you here
all our achievers it's a it's a mix of
all the four programs that we're running
this convocation program for
so this is for uh for data science data
analytics
aiml and business analysis so arjun you
can keep um
moving through the slides please do look
for your name and your photo and and
definitely this is a moment that we
would want you to cherish and and
celebrate and we are very happy to be
part of the celebration with you
so you will see that um so this time we
do have quite a few
few learners who have completed so which
itself is a mark
that there are a lot of few this is not
something that everybody can easily
achieve like i keep saying but this time
we have 200 plus
learners who have been able to complete
so today we have 50
attendance here but overall it's 200 so
as arjun keeps moving through the slides
you will see the number of you who have
completed it
and none of these programs have been
easy everything
you know it does take a lot of effort
and i think each one of you have
have put in your best effort and this is
just the outcome of it
so arjun we can quickly skip uh keep
moving
so uh the next few slides we have um
only the names because we were not we
did not get your photos
but please do look for your names here
congratulations to each one of you the
fact that we have so many slides is
extremely motivating for us to know that
so many of you were able to complete
this journey so congratulations
to each one of you
right so uh like like i mentioned
already
everybody here is an achiever today oh
but definitely we did want to call out
um
some of you who we call this superstars
among the achievers
and we have two award sections the first
one is the scholar award so this is
nothing but the
top two performance from each of the
cohort so here
the scholars from data science so
praveen kumar
congratulations to all of you you've
been nominated as scholars
uh scholars in ai ml sangeeta shishanks
shubhadeep
congratulations to all of you my
apologies if i'm pronouncing your name
wrong
gothami mohit arpita shaun chashmita
shweta cynthia congratulations to all of
you from data analytics
you've been nominated as scholars
business analysis scholars
namrata nasheed dhan sri rishi
muhammad and metre congratulations to
each one of you
the next award is the speedrunner award
this is the first two members who
completed the program from each of the
cohort and here are our winners
satish vishwanath amit anusha
raj ganesh surya madhavan
congratulations
to each one of you from the aiml program
the next is data science speedrunners
stensi rahul shubashu shibanshu i'm
sorry
priya sarita suman and
venus congratulations to each one of you
your speedrunners from the data
analytics programs
yashwanth anuja aditya
uh yusuf ali harini and kiran
congratulations to each one of you again
and runners from the business analysis
program
we have kumar hamanth sri bhargavi
savita
and mashmi das congratulations to each
one of you
and each one of you have done a
brilliant job a heartfelt
congratulations to every single learner
who is here
and learners who were not able to join
the event today i think this is a moment
of celebration and joy for all of us
uh equally for us because we were able
to be part of your journey
throughout and and really really happy
for you
as closing note i would like to request
abhishek mukherjee
our director for the the for the learner
experience org
to share a few words abhishek over to
you
thank you sabashini i hope i'm honorable
yes abhishek you're audible okay thank
you um
so i'll keep this short uh because we
are almost close
end of this of this program uh but first
of all
congratulations to all of you for
surviving and completing this
amazing learning journey i absolutely um
you know admire your perseverance uh
dedication and grit
to go through a program as tough as this
you all are diverse and accomplished
group um you know we have senior
executives
engineers phds
you know consultants analysts marketeers
but what you've really achieved or what
you've essentially acquired
through this program is you know a set
of skills and a certain
problem solving mindset that will help
you solve
tough business problems using data
essentially it will help you discover
patterns and insights from the chaos
that exists
in the sea of data that is created every
day in this world
some of you will apply these learnings
to build new products and companies
probably
and some may apply to new research areas
across science and medicine
but what i'm absolutely certain is that
all of you will
leave an impact on society at large with
your work
and as they say you know now the real
fun begins but today is a time to
celebrate
your success with with your friends and
families
so i wish you all the best for your
future endeavors
take care and and keep growing uh but
just one last thought
you now belong to a select group of
individuals who will keep the simply
learn flag
flying high so we would request you
uh to be part of the larger community uh
simply learn community thread that we
have
and help guide learners who will follow
you and your footsteps
in doing these extremely difficult
courses
so all the best again and uh very well
deserved i
i congratulate all the scholars and the
speed runners
but all of you indeed
so thank you and uh to use
thank you abhishek thank you for the
short but very very precise words from
you
uh thank you once again congratulations
to everybody and i think
this is definitely a moment for all of
us to cherish and celebrate
thank you for joining the event today
there will be a survey that will be
sent out right after this event ends
please do share your feedback with us we
are constantly looking at how we can
improve at every point and and as as we
move along uh
like everybody mentioned please do keep
in touch with your peers and with us
uh at any point that you would like to
reach out to us and we're always here to
help you
it's been a great evening and it's it's
a wonderful audience that we've had and
congratulations
to each one of you thank you so much for
being here today
thank you
you